des cyclistes le demander depuis 13 ans
pouvoir rouler 12 mois par année sur le
pont jacques cartier
leur attente est terminé et ce sont
trois ministres et deux députés du
gouvernement trudeau qui sont venu leur
annoncer sur leur vélo
c'est important pour nous parce que ça
fait partie de notre vision globale de
la question de la santé de la question
de l'environnement et de la question de
la mobilité la piste du pont jacques
cartier
on parle d'une moyenne de 2700 souza g
par jour où on se dit qu'il ya environ
entre cet acte et ma 15 à 20% d'un usage
estivale qui se poursuit
l'ibère la piste cyclable tout comme le
trottoirs pour les piétons et les
joggeurs de l'autre côté du pont seront
ouverts de 6 heures le matin à 22 heures
cet hiver le déneigement et le déglaçage
se feront surtout de nuit la neige sera
soufflée sur la première voie du pont
est aussi tout ramasser je n'ai qu'une
chose à répondre
alléluia il est est un symbole vagin
gauche donc vers la paix c'est
totalement sécuritaire
j'en sais un petit peu plus à risque
d'avoir des plaques de glace mais ses
compos l'âme mais si elle est rouge
on demande vraiment ce qui est de ne pas
l'utiliser françois des montagnes part
d'une grande victoire
il faisait partie des 25 cyclistes
choisi l'hiver dernier pour un projet
pilote au niveau de la qualité du
déneigement la société des ponts
jacques-cartier arrivait à vraiment une
super qualité même meilleur que
certaines pistes cyclables à montréal
donc là on les félicite à surveiller
c'est une façon de rouler l'hiver donc
on roule plus tranquille avec cette
ouverture le budget d'entretien hivernal
pour le pont jacques-cartier passera de
700 mille à un million de dollars par
année
montréal et la rive-sud auront donc
désormais deux liens cyclables pour les
relier hiver comme été
l'autre étant la piste du nouveau pont
samuel de champlain ici jean-sébastien
cloutier radio canada montréal